we decided to leave the country and went
on the run around Europe for a month
without giving any warning to our
friends and our family but once in
Europe of course the key thing was to
get through the airports to get into
Europe but once in Europe it was just
using trains
um no cars no flights no airports
nothing so you could just Hop On Hop Off
trains so it's just random traveling
literally across Western Europe for a
month
disguises only use cash
um never pre-book a hotel
because spies can track you
um yeah so it was very much a sort of
um gamekeeper Turned poacher scenario
because we knew how we would hunt
ourselves if we were investigating us